rebels who have staged a number of uh
rebellions in recent months uh one of
them around about a hundred mps critics
of course claim that the prime minister
is giving tory back benches what they
want because his position is precarious
because of all the allegations of
partying in downing street the threat of
letters to the chairman of the 1922
committee uh sir graham brady demanding
a vote of confidence in him and of
course a police investigation it's only
last friday that number 10 confirmed
that the pm had sent back his
questionnaire to the metropolitan police
about his involvement in gatherings in
number 10 which
it's claimed were parties he's claimed
in some of his uh statements that prime
minister's questions that they were work
events
um now uh the prime minister has been
under pressure he's uh rebuilt his team
inside number 10 he's changed his chief
whip leader he's that mark spencer's
move to the
post of leader of the house of commons
he's due to make a statement later this
afternoon on changing commons business
that may well be that we're going to get
some votes in the commons in the next
few days on getting rid of these coved
rules um
so there's been what some have called a
reset
of the prime minister's operation what
others have called steadying the ship i
must admit the ship didn't look very
steady earlier on today when cabinet
ministers went into downing street one
minute and came out the next that looked
very chaotic but we are told as i began
by saying that number 10 have said that
the cabinet has approved um
you gave cabinet gave unanimous backing
to the living with kovid's strategy so
um they were
we i can see in the house of commons
some of his most loyal supporters are on
the government front bench nadine doris
in particular for example uh one of his
real his chief cheerleader almost in the
cabinet um the chamber is really filling
up now it was fairly full for the
ukraine statement but it's filling up
now um
so we are my guess is that the statement
and the exchanges after uh p.m statement
will go on for a good um
hour and a half i would guess there's
just a few tory mps on their feet now so
i think we're coming towards the end
possibly of the ukraine statement but uh
there you can see the chamber on the
right hand side of your picture a few
gaps at this end of the chamber as you
can see on the right hand side that's
where the smp mps sit of course these
restrictions are for england only it's
worth uh pointing out and uh
that's uh i think one of the smp mps uh
speaking there um
and of course uh the leaders of uh the
welsh and scottish devolved
administrations have criticized the
prime minister particularly on the
proposal to end free testing um
and so uh there's steve barclay see uh
you perhaps can't see actually steve
barkley is next to
the uh the defense secretary uh he's
talking to nadine doris at the moment
and we are we are getting close to that
common statement peter bone i can tell
you is on his feet now
on ukraine but a lot of anticipation of
this big common statement from boris
johnson uh he the prime minister is not
yet in the chamber but cabinet ministers
are coming in the new chief whip is in
his place that chris that's chris heaton
harris one of the changes the prime
minister made um but we are going to
hear from the pm changes in england
should stress that this is just england
and it's the ending of isolation the
ending potentially of free testing or
those a suggestion perhaps over 80s
might continue to get free tests um be
interesting to see what the po has to
say about
those uh passenger locator forms for
when we all
go abroad they're controversial they're
unpopular may or may not get some
announcement to when they may go
but what we are expecting is that
self-isolation for testing positive will
go probably this thursday in a move that
will be cheered
loudly by the vast majority if not all
conservative mps as i say the prime
minister has called it a moment of pride
um the pm's moment of pride is fast
approaching although as i say mr wallace
is still talking about ukraine at the
moment that mata very much uh dominating
the commons so far this afternoon before
the pm uh enters the commons
and stands up to deliver that plan as it
has been agreed by him and cabinet today
john as you said there have been bumps
in the road in the build-up to this we
are expecting that statement as soon as
this uh debate on ukraine comes to a
close um following the statement in the
house of commons from the prime minister
john we are expecting a press conference
tonight what are we going to get in that
that's different to what we're going to
hear in a few minutes
um
not very much really i mean the the
prime minister will obviously
lay out his proposals in the same way as
he does in his common statement usually
the announcements don't differ the
questions are likely to be different
though
as opposed to mps obviously it's a
political and in some cases health
journalists i think we can possibly
expect a few more attempts to get the
prime minister to talk about whether
he's going to quit if he gets a fixed
penalty notice in a television interview
yesterday he was asked repeatedly if he
would quit if or if a prime minister
should quit if uh fined in a fixed
penalty notice uh i lost counter the
number of times he ducked that question
he said he would have more to say about
that when the police
police investigation was over so yes i
mean i would say this wouldn't i i'm
biased but i always reckon that
political journalists ask better
questions than members of parliament
they'd probably dispute that but uh okay
we'll get some tough questions from the
opposition but uh i'm i guess they'll be
a pretty warm welcome from the pa for
the pm uh from conservative backbenchers
the most hostile questions will
presumably come from the labour side and
the smp side i think i can see ian
blackford in his place in the chamber
that ct normally sits
below the gangway just opposite just to
the left of the uh government front
bench yes you guys you can see there in
blackford and his gray suit so just on
the right on the front row of the snp
benches but very few smp mps in the
chamber and in fact there's a few gaps
on the labor side as well actually you
can see there but look how packed those
tory benches are they're pretty full uh
they've been full for mr wallace's
statement and i guess probably uh they
will fill up even more you can see the
prime minister's just walked in so we
must literally be moments away now yes
yes indeed he uh prime minister's
questions he comes in when lindsey hoyle
calls him uh no doubt to get an even
bigger cheer my guess is uh i wasn't
able to hear if there was a chair this
time
i didn't see any waving of order papers
either but here's uh sir lindsay now on
his feet i think we're about to get
underway
we now come to this statement prime
minister
mr speaker with permission i'll make a
statement on our strategy for living
with kobe
and before i begin i know the whole
house will join me in sending our best
wishes to her majesty the queen
[Music]
for a full and swift recovery
it is a reminder that this virus has not
gone away
but because of the efforts we've made as
a country over the past two years
we can now deal with it in a very
different way
moving from government restrictions to
personal responsibility so we protect
ourselves without losing our liberties
and maintaining our contingent
capabilities so we can respond rapidly
to any new variant mr speaker the uk was
the first country in the world to
administer an approved vaccine and the
first european nation to protect half
our population with at least one dose
and having made that decision to refocus
our nhs this winter on the campaign to
get boosted now
we were the first major european nation
to boost half our population too
and it's because of the extraordinary
success of this vaccination program that
we've been able to lift our restrictions
earlier than other comparable countries
opening up last summer while others
remained closed and keeping things open
this winter while others shut down again
making us one of the most open economies
and societies in europe with the fastest
growth anywhere in the g7 last year
and while the pandemic is not over
we have now passed the peak of the
omicron wave with cases falling
hospitalizations in england now fewer
than 10 000
and still falling
and the link between infection and
severe disease substantially weakened
over 71
of all adults are now boosted in england
including 93
of those age 70 and over
and together with the treatments and
scientific understanding of the virus
that we've built up we now have
sufficient levels of immunity to
complete the transition from protecting
people with government interventions
to relying on vaccines and treatments as
our first line of defense
as we have throughout the past two years
we will continue to work closely with
the devolved administrations as they
decide how to take forward their own
plans
and today's strategy shows how we will
structure our approach in england
around four principles
first
we will remove
all remaining
domestic restrictions in law
[Music]
from this thursday 24th of february we
will end the legal requirement to
self-isolate following a positive test
and so we will also end self-isolation
support payments although covered
provisions for statutory sick pay can
still be claimed for a further month
we will end routine contact tracing
and no longer ask fully vaccinated
closed contacts and those under 18 to
test daily for seven
days and we will remove the legal
requirement for close contacts who are
not fully vaccinated to self-isolate
until the first of april we will advise
people who test positive to stay at home
but after that we will encourage people
with copied 19 symptoms
to exercise
personal responsibility
just as we encourage people who may have
flu to be considerate
to others
mr speaker
it's only because
levels of immunity are so high and
deaths are now if anything below where
you would normally expect for this time
of year that we can lift these
restrictions and it's only because we
know omicron is less severe
that testing for omicron on the colossal
scale we've been doing is much less
important and much less valuable in
preventing serious illness
we should be proud that the uk has
established the biggest testing program
per person
of any large country in the world
this came at vast cost
the test trace and isolation budget in
20 20 to 23 21 exceeded the entire
budget of the home office
it cost a further 15.7 billion pounds in
this financial year and 2 billion pounds
in january alone at the height of the
omicron wave
we must now scale this back
from today we're removing the guidance
for staff and students in most education
and child care settings to undertake
twice weekly asymptomatic taste testing
and from the first of april
where winter is over and the virus will
spread less easily we will end free
symptomatic and asymptomatic testing for
the general public
we will continue to provide free
symptomatic tests to the oldest age
groups and those most vulnerable to
coped
and in line with the practice in many
other countries we're working with
retailers to ensure that everyone who
wants to can buy a test
from april the 1st we will also no
longer recommend the use of voluntary
covered status certification
although the nhs app will continue to
allow people to indicate their
vaccination status for international
travel
mr speaker the government will also
expire all temporary provisions of the
coronavirus act
of the original 40 20 have already
expired and 16 will expire on the 24th
of march
and the last four relating to
innovations in public service will
expire six months later after we have
made those improvements permanent via
other means
second we will continue to protect the
most vulnerable with targeted vaccines
and treatments
the uk government has procured enough
doses of vaccine to anticipate a wide
range of possible jcvi
recommendations
and today we're taking further action to
guard against a possible resurgence of
the virus
accepting jcvi jcvi advice for a new
spring booster offered to those aged 75
and older to older care home residents
and those over 12 who are
immunosuppressed
the uk is also
leading the way on antivirals and
therapeutics with our antivirals task
force securing a supply of almost five
million
more per head than any other country in
europe
third sage advised there is considerable
uncertainty about the future path of the
pandemic and there may of course be
significant resurgences
they are certain there will be new
variants and it is very possible they
will be worse than omicron
so we will maintain our resilience to
manage and respond to these risks
including our world leading ons survey
which will allow us to continue tracking
the virus in granular detail
with regional with regional and age
breakdowns helping us to spot surges as
and where they happen
and our laboratory networks will help us
understand the evolution of the virus
and identify any changes in
characteristics
we will prepare and maintain our
capabilities to ramp up testing
we will continue to support other
countries in developing their own
surveillance capabilities because a new
variant can emerge anywhere
and we will meet our commitment to
donate 100 million vaccine doses by june
as part of our agreement at the uk's g7
summit to provide a billion doses to
vaccinate the world over the next year
in all circumstances
our aim will be to manage and respond to
future risks
through more routine public health
interventions with pharmaceutical
interventions as the first line of
defense
fourth we will build on the innovation
that has defined the best of our
response to the pandemic
the vaccines task force will continue to
ensure that the uk has access to
effective vaccines as they become
available already securing contracts
with manufacturers trialling bivalent
vaccines which would provide protection
against covid variants
the therapeutics task force will
continue to support seven national
priority clinical trial platforms
focused on prevention
novel treatments and treatments for long
cobit
we are refreshing our bio-security
strategy to protect the uk against
natural zoonosis
and accidental laboratory leaks as well
as the potential for biological threats
emanating from state and non-state
actors
and building on the five-point plan i
set out at the un and the agreements
reached at the uk's g7 last year we are
working with our international partners
on future pandemic preparedness
including through a new pandemic treaty
an effective early warning system or
global pandemic radar and a mission to
make safe and effective diagnostics
therapeutics and vaccines available
within the first 100 days of a future
pandemic threat being island identified
and we will be hosting a global pandemic
preparedness summit next month
mr speaker
kovid will not
suddenly disappear
so those who would wait for a total end
to this war before lifting the remaining
regulations
would be restricting the liberties of
the british people for a long time to
come
this government does not believe that
that is right or necessary
restrictions pose a heavy toll on our
economy
our society our mental well-being and on
the life chances of our children and we
do not need to pay that cost any longer
we have a population that is protected
by the biggest vaccination program in
our history we have the antivirals the
treatments and the scientific
understanding of this virus and we have
the capabilities to respond rapidly to
any resurgence or new variant and mr
speaker it is time that we got our
confidence back we don't need laws to
compel people to be considerate to
others we can rely on that sense of
responsibility towards one another
providing practical advice in the
knowledge that people will follow it to
avoid infecting loved ones and others
so let us learn
to live with this virus
and continue protecting ourselves and
others without restricting our freedoms
and in that spirit mr speaker i commend
this statement to the house
[Music]
can i just
mr sherman please
can just say i understand the state was
important and the prime minister did not
know so i'm more than happy for the
opposition leaders to also run over kia
stammer
thank you mr speaker can i start by
sending my condolences to the family of
christopher stalford
christopher was a dedicated servant of
the people of south belfast and his loss
will be deeply felt
i'd also like to send our best wishes to
her majesty the queen and as the prime
minister said the whole house wishes her
a speedy recovery
[Music]
can i thank the prime minister for
advanced copy of his statement and for
the briefing earlier this afternoon
mr speaker huge efforts have been made
over the last two years
and we would not be where we are today
without the heroism of our nhs and key
workers
those who pioneered and rolled out the
vaccines
and the sacrifices
that people made every day
to follow the rules and protect our
public health
we must honor the collective sacrifices
of the british people and do everything
possible to prevent a return to the loss
and lockdowns we've seen over the last
two years
the prime minister promised to present a
plan for living with covid
but all we've got today is yet more
chaos and disarray
not enough to prepare us for the new
variants which may yet develop
an approach which seems to think that
living with cove it means simply
ignoring it
this morning he couldn't even persuade
his own health secretary to agree the
plan so what confidence can the public
have that this is the right approach
mr speaker let me be clear the labour
party does not want to see restrictions
in place for a moment longer than
necessary
but mr speaker we have to take the
public with us
and that requires clarity
order if you can't show the respect that
i expect the prime minister to be heard
inside i expect lead with the opposition
if you don't wish to be in here there's
plenty of room outside this chamber i
suggest you start using it and i'll be
helping you on your way so let's have
silence kirsten
uh mr speaker we have to take the public
with us and that requires clarity about
why decisions are being made
so will the prime minister publish the
scientific evidence behind his decision
to remove the legal requirement to
self-isolate including the impact on the
clinically extremely vulnerable
for whom lockdown has never ended
having come this far
i know the british people will continue
to act responsibly
and they will do the right thing testing
and then isolating if positive
what i can't understand is why the prime
minister is taking away the tools that
will help them to do that
free tests can't continue forever but if
you're 2-1 up with if you're
if you're 2-1 up with 10 minutes to go
you don't sub off one of your best
defenders
[Music]
the prime minister
the prime minister is also removing
self-isolation support payments that
allow many people to isolate and
weakening sick pay
these are decisions which will hit the
lowest paid and the most insecure
workers the hardest
including care workers who got us
through the toughest parts of the
pandemic
it's all very well advising workers to
self-isolate
but that won't work unless all workers
have security of knowing that they can
afford to do so
the prime minister mentioned
surveillance and the ons infection
survey
this is crucial to ensuring that we can
ramp up testing and vaccination if the
virus returns
so can the prime minister confirm that
he has put the funding in place to
ensure that the ons infection survey
will not see reduced capacity and that
it will be able to track the virus with
the same degree of detail as it can
today
we can't turn off british britain's
radar
before the war is won
ignorance's bliss is not a responsible
approach to a deadly virus
it actually risks undoing all the
hard-won progress the british people
have achieved over the last two years
mr speaker the labour party has
published a comprehensive plan for
living well with covid
our plan would see us learn the lessons
of the past two years and prepared for
new variants
his approach will leave us vulnerable
where's the plan to secure the uk supply
of testing why are skilled schools still
not properly ventilated
as a nation there is no doubt we need to
move on from covid
people need to know their liberties are
returning and returning for good
but this is a half-baked announcement
from a government paralysed by chaos and
incompetence it is not a plan
to live well with kobe
[Music]
minister
and mr speaker i really thought this was
going to be the moment when he would end
uh his his run of making the wrong call
on every single one
of the big decisions but mr speaker time
and time again uh he's had the chance to
back the government uh on the big
decisions and i'm afraid that he's got
it wrong just to turn to some of the
points that he's that he's made the the
evidence for what we're doing today is
is amply there in the scientific
government's in in the in the figures
for the rates of infections that i've
outlined today uh and in all the data
that is that is freely available uh to
members of of the house and they can see
what's happening with infection rates
with mortality uh with with what omicron
is doing across the country mr speaker
he asks about the clinic leagues
extremely vulnerable and that's a a of
course an entirely uh reasonable
question but what we are going to do is
make sure that they continue to be
protected uh with with with uh
priority access to therapeutics and of
course uh to vaccines as well he asked
about about testing mr speaker which is
absolutely satirical because week after
week month after month i've listened to
the uh to the labor party mr speaker
complaining about nhs testing denouncing
the cost denouncing the costs did you
not hear the mrs because denied seeing
the cost of nhs tests and trace and now
now they want to continue with it uh
when mr speaker we do not need to go on
with it in the way uh that we are
currently doing so he asked about he
asked about our ability to uh to do
tests or our domestic ability to
manufacture tests it's as though he
doesn't know mr speaker that we have in
this country now one of the biggest
manufacturers of battleflow tests uh in
uh in uh in europe uh mr speaker uh this
is a a a leader of the opposition who as
i say has shown an absolutely
ferocious grip
of the wrong end of the stick
he never she never ceases to
he never ceases to remain he was wrong
uh on july the 19th if you remember
totally wrong he said we shouldn't open
up on on july the 19th uh he said uh
that we the labour party that there he
has said that we needed a roadmap back
into lockdown mr speaker
during december
they wanted to stay they wanted he voted
several times they wanted to stay in the
european medicine agency
contrary to his denials in this house mr
speaker he voted several times uh to do
so uh he's been consistently wrong on
all the big calls uh he was wrong then
he's wrong now what we are doing mr
speaker is moving forward in a balanced
sensible and proportionate way
moving forward away from legal
compulsion in a way that i think the
british people understand and trusting
in them and trusting in their great
sense of personal responsibility
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you mr speaker i support today's
announcement which is a tribute to
british science
leadership in the vaccine programme does
the prime minister agree when it comes
to future pandemics that the real danger
zone are those early months when we
don't have a vaccine against a new virus
and in that context it's not just
whether the nhs can cope but whether the
nhs can cope without switching off other
vital life-saving treatments
and if he agrees with that that it is
not just enough to say
that we have more doctors and nurses
than we had before
but that we also need to make sure we
have enough doctors for the future and
if he has plans for that would he please
tell the house how he will make sure
that we are actually training enough
i i thank my right-hand friend very much
and he's returning he's returning to a
theme he's returning to a theme that uh
he's mentioned several times we have a a
a vast plan mr speaker to recruit and
more nurses and more doctors than ever
before there already are more in the in
the nhs than that uh at any time
we have 25 000 more now this year uh
healthcare professionals than there were
last year mr speaker and we will
continue to fund them
leader of the snp in blackford
thank you
mr speaker
this statement was billed as a
prime minister's moment of pride
but it's clear
that this morning has been a moment of
panic for this government disagreement
across whitehall and a lack of any
serious engagement
with the devolved nations shows that
these decisions are bereft of science or
consultation
it appears these dangerous choices
are purely political and have been made
up on the hoof
it is another symptom of a government in
turmoil
the illogical reality
of uk finance means that these decisions
made for england by a failing prime
minister
affect the money the devolved nations
have to provide testing
it is unacceptable
that the ability to protect
money i hear money we're talking about
protecting the people of scotland
something that this prime minister is
back on
and it's unacceptable that the ability
to protect her population can be
imperiled on the basis of a political
decision
taken by a prime minister in crisis
his decisions directly affect whether
scotland has the funding required to
keep its people safe
that is the ridiculous reality of
devolution but it's a reality that must
be addressed
so will the prime minister now confirm
what the residual funding for testing
will be
to enable the scottish government to
pick up the pieces of this chaotic
withdrawal of support
mr speaker
it makes the case for scotland to take
necessary measures to keep our people
safe we need the financial ability to
make our own choices
that mr speaker only comes with
independence
mr speaker
i will also hear the leader of the
opposition in science i don't need the
burger king he certainly doesn't need i
don't need in blackfoot
thank you mr speaker
pcr testing the legal requirement to
self-isolate and access to lateral flow
testing have been instrumental
instrumental prime minister and
containing the virus
as we move forward to live with covet
these are the very safeguards which
support a return to normal life and
these short-sighted decisions have
long-term implications they also hamper
vital surveillance efforts and impede
the ability to respond to new variants
mr speaker the reality is that we have a
prime minister beset by chaos admired
any police investigation for breaking
his own covert laws and he can shake his
head but that's the reality mr speaker a
prime minister
who has no moral authority to lead
desperately seeking to appease his back
ventures we know this reckless statement
flies in the face of advice from
scientists at the world health
organization that's because this
statement is not about protecting the
public it's about the prime minister
scrambling to save his own skin
[Applause]
[Music]
well mr speaker you wouldn't believe it
from uh what the right honourable
gentleman has just said but the
cooperation uh between the uk government
the scottish authority has been
outstanding and and will continue to be
outstanding and i'm
and i can i can tell him uh he asked
about free free tests and how they're to
be paid for it's very important the free
test will of course continue until the
beginning of april and uh and of course
uh if if people want if people want to
continue uh beyond then and i and i set
out for the house uh the reasons why we
think it's much more sensible to focus
mr speaker on surveillance and spotting
new variants putting up put our
investment into that rather than uh
rather than mass testing then he has mr
speaker access to the 41 41 billion a
record uh settlement that that
he has under uh under violet and he also
mr speaker has access to hundreds of
millions hundreds of millions from uh
the health and care levy the only
astonishing thing is that he voted
against him
thank you mr speaker i warmly welcome
the statement that the prime minister
has made
the prime minister will also be aware
of growing international evidence that
lockdowns have been largely ineffective
in preventing covered mortality and
we're acutely aware of the massive
damage which has been done
economically and to non-covet health
of the people due to lockdowns will he
review pandemic planning for the future
to make sure these crucial lessons are
learned
yes i i thank my my right honourable
friend and he's right to draw attention
to all sorts of studies about the
efficacy of lockdowns we'll look at all
the evidence i happen to think that the
actions of the collective actions of the
british public were indispensable in
saving uh many many thousands of of
lives uh mr speaker but i'm sure that
all the evidence will be looked at in
the course of the inquiry
hillary ben
thank you very much indeed mr speaker
new antiviral drugs have made a huge
difference to the treatment
of covid they are indeed as the prime
minister says the first line of defense
but they work best when given early now
one of the requirements at the moment in
order to qualify
to get an antiviral drug
is that the person has tested positive
for covert if the prime minister is
going to get rid of free lateral flow
tests how people are going to get access
to those medicines
mr speaker obviously um great respect
for the great respect to the right
environment
people who are who are symptomatic will
of course continue to have access to
testing
it's a birthday person sir brett liv
[Music]
our historic vaccine program is the
reason that we're in this position today
and i want to take this opportunity to
thank everybody involved in harvard and
haslam and for the roll out of the
vaccination program and those who have
had to deal with the restrictions for
longer than most but does the prime
minister agree with me that this is
exactly why we must learn to live with
the virus due to how damaging
restrictions can be on mental health and
well-being
[Music]
[Applause]
mr speaker my my honourable friend is is
absolutely right and uh we have to set
all these decisions the cost of
lockdowns the cost of uh
on people's mental health and well-being
against the the difficult decisions that
we have to make about opening up our
society and i think the house
understands that i think this is a a
balanced decision that is entirely right
i should just clarify to the right
honourable gentleman uh that of course
uh those who are vulnerable uh who are
symptomatic will of course continue to
have access to testing and i should i
should have said that uh in my answer to
this question let's go barbra keeley
thank you mr speaker in a recent survey
the majority of nhs leaders agreed it
was not the right time to end free
testing for the public can the prime
minister tell me why he disagrees with
those nhs leaders and what scientific
advice he has considered to come to this
decision which could have
could have a real impact on the nhs
elective recovery plan
i i i hear the the anxieties of of uh of
people uh but i have to say that i think
that this is the balance and the right
sort of testing and i just remind her of
what uh her benches have previously said
about the cost of of testing uh we now
think that the uh the the best thing to
focus on is given the
the severity of omicron the best thing
is to focus on surveillance and to use
the huge funds that were currently
dedicating uh to mass testing on
electives and all the other things that
we need to do clark
mr speaker so andrew pollard of the
oxford vaccine group said this morning
that it doesn't make a big difference
whether the decision to lift these
restrictions is taken now on a few weeks
time so it's not clear what the purpose
of waiting any longer would be
but one of the things that we do know in
the past is at times we didn't have the
testing capacity that we needed at times
when we needed it most acutely
so given the ongoing surveillance if
that were to throw up a variant that was
more dangerous than omicron how quickly
can we stand up and deploy again mass
testing
i thank him and that's that's exactly
the right question mr speaker and that's
why we're putting so much emphasis on
surveillance on the ons uh with its
amazing granular ability to uh detect
what is going on in uh in in local areas
as well as as well as other uh forms of
surveillance we want to spot the the new
variant of concern as soon as we can mr
speaker then we want that we want to
surge our testing capacity in the way
that we did uh before and of course much
faster now since it is all ready to go
we will have stockpiles mr speaker we
will keep our labs in readiness and we
will be able uh to surge where necessary
but now is not the right time to
continue with mass testing from april it
will not be the right time to continue
uh with mass testing in the way that we
have david
can i join the prime minister in sending
our very best wishes to her majesty the
queen and hope she gets well soon
mr speaker there are millions of family
carers across our country
taking regular lateral flow tests to
ensure they don't pass kovid onto their
vulnerable loved ones
the prime minister now says these
families carers must pay for covid tests
out of their own pocket
even though so many family carers can
hardly make ends meet at the moment
is a prime minister really telling
people they must choose between money
for the weekly shop or a test so they
don't accidentally take this contagious
virus into their loved ones homes
surely such a tax on caring would be
unfair and unjust
mr speaker my own friend is right to
draw attention to uh the need to pro pro
rojama's right to draw an attention need
to protect uh care homes and those who
work in uh in care homes uh
he should he should wait until uh
until march when we'll be setting out in
more detail those who will be uh who
will continue to be entitled to free
tests
the man for the rules matt hancock thank
you very much mr speaker mr speaker
almost two years ago now this house
voted
unanimously
on the statutory measures necessary to
keep people safe during the pandemic
and i agree with the prime minister that
now thanks to the vaccines these
measures are no longer necessary and
indeed that we're the first major
country in the world to be past the
pandemic
but isn't it extraordinary
that despite that consensus on
restrictions back then
the consensus on giving people back
their freedom which is often so much
harder and trusting to personal
responsibility that consensus appears
only to exist on this side of the house
[Applause]
yes mr speaker i think it's a great
shame
uh that the uh opposition cannot find it
in themselves uh to to support what i
think is a balanced and proportionate
approach and one mr speaker that
recognizes that kobe has not gone away
and that we cannot uh throw a caution to
the wins
london
mr speaker given everything else the
prime minister said this afternoon why
is he keeping
uh the bureaucratic and irritating
passenger locator form when the whole of
the rest of europe when the whole of the
rest of europe can already travel freely
by showing a vaccine certificate
right well
a welcome welcome call for liberty uh
from the off from the
opposition benches but uh i can tell him
that we already have one of the most
open uh travel arrangements travel
systems uh in the world and the
passenger locator form i understand his
grievance against it we are certainly uh
reviewing it by easter
so john redwood great news that our
freedoms are being restored so can the
prime minister
so can the prime minister now bring that
same focus and government in innovation
shown on this topic to vanquish the cost
of living crisis so that more people
have enough money to enjoy the freedoms
yes all right
all right you bet mr speaker
thank you mr speaker
and we do not know how well the vaccine
works on immuno compromised people and
they and their loved ones will rightly
be extremely worried and as the
honourable member for lee central raised
there are delays in getting test results
thus delaying access to life-saving
anti-virals
can we allow them to have a supply of
antivirals at home because if his
pharmaceutical interventions would save
lives
let's make sure that they can access
them asap
mr speaker we've already secured more uh
antivirals and therapeutics per head
than any other uh country in in europe
uh and uh what we need to do is ensure
uh that to those who are those who are
clinically extremely vulnerable uh do
have access to them and then 1.3 million
of them have already been sent tests
hold on mummy crop
mr speaker whilst the threat from covid
has changed thanks in no small part to
the outstanding vaccination efforts led
by my honourable friend the prime
minister he will know that the effects
on local hospitals will last for years
to come does he agree with me that now
is the right time to invest in upgrades
to hospitals like scum yeah
now is now is the exactly the right time
to speak to invest in hospitals like
skunkthorpe uh across the country i i i
cannot give a
commitment to
the particular project that she
described but it is it is the kind of
project mr speaker 48 of which as you
know mr speaker we are progressing
across the country
first of all can i welcome the fact that
we're having these restrictions left and
i hope that the prime minister will
engage with the health minister in
northern ireland to make sure that the
same
measures are
exercised in northern ireland the prime
minister said though
that it is important that we get our
confidence back
we have lived through two years of fear
being instilled in the population can he
tell us what nudge tactics he now
intends to engage in to ensure that that
confidence is restored so people can get
back to work back into the shops and
restaurants and back doing the things
which make life enjoyable
parties
perhaps i could begin mr speaker by uh
echoing the condolences for the dup mla
uh christopher uh christopher salford
and uh uh mr speaker just i i agree
wholly with his uh with his sentiments
uh we do need people to uh to get their
their confidence back as i as i said the
other day and what i think people can do
they can they can set an example they
can uh they can they can they can go go
to work mr speaker i think go go going
to work is that are you waiting to see
going to work mr speaker david davis
cheer up the prime minister by welcoming
what he has to say today
[Applause]
and say to him the the comment of the
leader of the opposition that the
government had no plan to deal with this
was destroyed by his own uh friend
honorable right honourable friend the
member for lead central who pointed out
that
antiviral therapeutics were incredibly
effective 95 effective against this
disease and am i right can the prime
minister confirm that we have 203 two
and three quarter million courses of
such of such therapeutics available to
us
right already i know mr speaker i can't
confirm that like well i can tell him in
fact we have twice the amount uh
million dollars okay caroline lucas
thank you very much uh mr speaker living
with covert does not mean ignoring it
and he will be aware that lifting of
restrictions today flies in the face of
advice from many nhs leaders and health
experts including the bma and the world
health organization and saying everyone
should take personal responsibility
while at the very same time taking away
the very means that would allow them to
take that personal response
responsibility is utterly perverse so
what would he say to those of my
constituents particularly those who are
clinically extremely vulnerable for whom
his freedom day is a day of profound
fear and loss of freedom and would he
clarify his response to the right
honourable member for kingston and
serbian because it's not just an issue
of free testing for people in care homes
it's a question of free testing at the
very least for the almost 7 million
carers up and down this country
[Music]
so just on that uh mr speaker she should
wait as i said to uh to her honourable
uh right honourable friend from kingston
and serbian and on on the clinically
extremely vulnerable i think it's very
important to remember that uh they do
have and we will continue as we have
throughout the pandemic uh to look after
them with all the therapeutics that we
can uh with vaccines where where that's
where that's appropriate as you know uh
the house knows the the shielding
program ended in in september but i
think what people need to recognize with
the with the cv with the clinically
extremely vulnerable is that we should
treat them with uh with with caution
just as uh we anybody uh with any
respiratory disease uh should treat the
clinically extremely vulnerable with
caution respect them and act with
responsibility
mr speaker and i fully uh endorse the
prime minister's statement it's a
significant step forward but whilst also
wanting to get more confidence back into
the country people also want some
consistency so they can plan ahead and
to that end will he look at what we do
with schools and education more
generally particularly around making
them an essential part of our national
infrastructure so that in any future
occasions where we may be considering
restrictions across the country schools
nurseries colleges and universities at
the very back of that hue so that we
make sure that that lost learning we saw
during this pandemic doesn't happen
again
my my undergrad makes an excellent point
and that's why we're ensuring that
schools are able to
be as coveted secure as possible uh inc
sending out uh 350 000 co2 uh monitors 9
000 air cleaning units amongst other
steps that we're taking uh to protect
schools and i think it's very very
important uh that we should get the
message over uh to everybody that
schools are safe and not one of one of
the many things mr speaker that the
leader of the opposition got wrong
alex davis jones
the prime minister in outlining his
reckless plan for living with corvid
announced that he is relying on the
british public to apply personal
responsibility when it comes to the
virus
does this also apply to the prime
minister
she says it's a she says it's a reckless
plan mr speaker that was exactly the
word that the right honourable general
lead of the opposition used to describe
the july 19th openings i wonder whether
she still believes that i'll carpool
mr speaker um i'll take the prime
minister's statement if i may as his
application to join the kovid recovery
group he's very welcome indeed i only
wish it had been uh sooner um
can i ask him a question though on um
all of the lockdowns and the serious
restrictions have all been implemented
using the public health act some of them
by ministerial decree
only approved by parliament
retrospectively
if we're to believe that next time will
be different
why doesn't this plan include proposals
to change the public health act to make
uh ministers more accountable to
parliament now
rather than kicking it into the long
grasp waiting for the results of the
covid public inquiry
well i i know that my uh my right
honourable friend is a staunch
thatcherite and he will recall it was
margaret thatcher who actually uh
promulgated the public health act in
1984.
and uh we
it has served this country well for a
long time i'll consider uh the point
that he uh that he makes it is a it is a
valuable one uh but i think it may also
be something that the inquiry will uh
want to consider themselves dr philippa
whitford thank you very much mr speaker
with 38 000 new covert cases today can
the prime minister explain
which public health experts advised
abandoning testing in isolation and when
will that advice be published
[Music]
yes i i thank her very much and ca as
you know cases uh are falling
hospitalizations
hospitalizations are falling and and the
number of excess deaths uh from omicron
is in is in is actually in in negative
uh territory and uh we consult a wide
range of scientific opinion including uh
including sage and and clearly uh csa
and cmo uh but the decisions are for
ministers and we take them the anderson
thank you mr speaker
now then unlike the opposition the prime
minister has got all the big decisions
right through the pandemic
but will he agree with me that we should
never return to a full lockdown and any
isolation should be targeted it should
be the clinically vulnerable the elderly
and the labour front bench
mr speaker
my honorable friend has put it
brilliantly and succinctly and i have
nothing to add
chris brian thank you mr speaker liberty
is always better than the alternative
as long as everybody can share in that
liberty equally
so the anxiety for some of us especially
those who represent very poor
communities
is that if you are symptomatic and free
testing is ended you may end up having
to pay 59 pounds 119 pounds for a pcr
test
and then on top of that if you if you do
the responsible thing and stay away from
work you may be in a job where you're
not going to get any money at all
or you're going to get pathetic sick pay
don't we have to make sure if we are
going to make sure that everybody shares
in that liberty equally that the poorest
in britain get a better deal
[Applause]
the right honourable gentleman uh makes
a very important point but i think that
overwhelmingly first of all there will
be statutory sick pay uh available but
but but secondly i think he i think if i
may say so i think he he underestimates
people's sense of responsibility and
also and also uh people's people's
willingness to do the right thing by
others
speaker i welcome what the prime
minister has set out today and i
especially welcome his commitment to
scunny hospital
and i also welcome him his continuation
of the ons survey study not least
because my mom and dad have been taking
part in it and it's uh giving them
something to do throughout the course of
uh covert um rather than text me
constantly um but can i on nhs testing
and somebody who knows that works in the
nhs myself i i like getting my test
before i book on duty it makes me feel
safe when i'm going into care homes to
attend patients or elsewhere so as he
sets out how testing will continue in
march can he uh set out clearly what the
situation will be for testing of nhs
workers
uh i can first of all thank my honorable
friend very much for his service uh in
the nhs and throughout the the pandemic
uh and and i've seen him in action but
also uh to to say that uh on his on his
point about the nhs uh that will be for
the nhs to determine themselves yeah
florence session lobby
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
mentioned this afternoon it's about
personal responsibility and it is
it's about our personal responsibility
not to inadvertently pass on that virus
to someone who's vulnerable it's about
our personal responsibility to do the
right thing if we have the symptoms and
if we have covid it's about our personal
responsibility to think about our
neighbors our friends our carers the
people who need those restrictions
lifted what does my prime minister what
does the prime minister have to say to
my vulnerable constituents in vauxhall
who are concerned that this personal
responsibility that the prime minister
wants us to take may inadvertently lead
to them catching kovid
prime minister i i i i i thank her very
much and uh she's right to to focus on
personal responsibility but the other
part of the strategy is the vaccinations
and this is a vaccine-led strategy and
that's what enables us that and that's
what enables us now uh to rely on
people's personal responsibility as well
the manchester united thank you mr
speaker can i very much welcome the
statement by the uh prime minister and
the way he set out the argument with
regards to living with kovid in
respecting restoring people's freedoms
and at the same time
with regards to protecting public health
the key advance that we have for future
prime minister is that we have the
mapping exercise with vaccination
centers already in place such as the
medway with that being the case will
promise also thank the excellent
volunteers and the nhs staff in medway
and look at their bid for a new medway
hospital in my constituency
mr speaker i don't be careful what i say
about more hot but we want to build as
many hospitals as we possibly can uh but
we'll have to look at his uh look at
this plan i do want to thank the medway
uh volunteers i think everybody's still
involved in the in the backstage
campaign uh there are still millions of
people mr speaker who have not yet had
uh their booster and i urged them to get
it yeah yeah
catherine west thank you mr speaker it's
lovely to have the prime minister with
us today not filling in his
questionnaires or having his busy
meetings with the police
[Music]
mr speaker
can he confirm or deny the reports that
there is a sell-off plan to the vaccine
manufacturing and innovation center
which has been founded on the values and
the mission of people like dr sarah
gilbert who invented the astrazeneca
vaccination there are rumors going about
that this public-private enterprise will
be sold off to the private sector will
he confirm or deny what is the
government's intention because the
essence of the reason that we were ahead
with the vaccine
was the excellence and the values of
those wonderful british scientists who
worked
their socks off to get this don't just
sell it off
mr speaker i might also add that uh one
of the uh most important factors in the
success of the of the vaccine rollout
was the private sector and it was it was
it was private sector investment uh mr
speaker uh that led to uh the the
astrazeneca uh vaccine the fisa vaccines
and uh we will make sure that we work
with the private sector uh to continue
to develop this country's
native indigenous ability to manufacture
mrna and other types of vaccines
speaker keeping healthy people at home
in isolation has had a devastating
impact on lives businesses and important
life events like weddings so i welcome
these changes uh to trust the british
people
and to allow people to plan with
confidence yet we all have constituents
who are immune
and they're vulnerable like the woman
who wrote to me this morning and unlike
what the opposition budgets say they do
not have a monopoly on compassion we
care about these people will my right
honourable friend just reassure again
that these people will get the support
they need and that the timing is right
and there's no point in waiting for
these changes
yes she's absolutely right mr speaker
and we'll make sure that
those people get uh not just the the
antivirals that they need but also the
tests that they need
karen smith
um mr deputy speaker i think that's the
point i would really like clarification
from the promise because i think we've
learned today that the seven million
carers won't get tests nhs staff and
care staff will have to be found within
existing budgets thus making those
waiting lists even more precarious but
eligibility for antivirals is based on
being over 12 being at high risk having
symptoms or testing positive for kovid19
for which people will have to pay can
the prime minister confirm that that is
the case and i see this health secretary
is helping him out but if you could
clarify that for people that'd be really
helpful
mr speaker she will if she waits a
little bit longer uh she will get she
will she will she will she will get
a breakdown of how we propose to support
the most vulnerable but we will support
them uh mr speaker as we have done
throughout the pandemic rapidly
experts will argue for years when we've
made the right choices and some of us
for what it's worth would have liked to
like to touch
but one thing is certain and we know
this from independent testimony which
has emerged from a former adviser of the
prime minister the but for his
freedom-loving instincts and libertarian
instincts these lockdowns would have
been much longer and much worse with
incarcerable consequences for the young
and people's mental health so can we
rely on the prime minister in the future
to rule out any more lockdowns in the
coming decade while he remains prime
minister
what you can certainly rely on mr
speaker is that this government will
take the tough decisions to protect the
british people and we will have a
vaccine and science-led uh approach to
dealing with this pandemic simon
bolhatter
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
has come to the house today unable to
state whether carers in our communities
visiting home after home in one day
often of older people and those who are
clinically extremely vulnerable will
still have access to free tests in order
to keep themselves and their patients
and clients safe he has now said that
testing for nhs staff will be a matter
for the nhs
surely he can do better than this
even the nhs and carers need to be able
to plan ahead for what is coming won't
he come clean with the house today about
his intentions
mr speaker what we're doing is moving
away from a systematic mass testing
of mass testing of large numbers of
people uh which is no longer the right
way to deal with omicron
to a surveillance-led approach and of
course we will continue
uh to look after the most vulnerable and
those who need it mr speaker
thank williams thank you mr speaker can
i welcome the path to freedom the prime
minister has set out
and i am sure that as the leader of
opposition the welsh first minister will
condemn the plan today but in about two
weeks present the same plan as his own
so could i ask my prior prime minister
to reach out to the labour first
minister and the other devolved
administrations who we have worked well
with when ugly nationalism is put aside
to get those freedoms for the residents
of montgomery as quickly as possible
i
i i thank my honourable friend and i i i
indeed as i i extend the hand of
corporation to uh our scottish uh
friends of the scottish administration
uh i hope that the uh the welsh
administration and cardiff uh will will
see the way forward uh and
as i've said many times before the
similarities in our approach greatly
outweigh the differences
clive effort
okay so imagine that this is the prime
minister that missed five kobe five
cobra meetings at the start of this
pandemic my constituent who spoke to me
yesterday was immunosuppressed
anticipated the difficulties that the
prime minister is having over testing
for people who are
who are clinically vulnerable
she wanted to know whether she was going
to have ready access to free tests and
whether she was going to get ready
access to antivirals should she test
positive and what is the situation that
those people are being plunged in today
yeah
i i thank you very much the answer to
those questions is yes and yes so uh for
the for the 1.3 cv clinically 1.3
million uh clinically extremely
vulnerable they uh will of course be uh
given access to testing uh free testing
mr speaker and uh they will also have
access to the largest quantity of uh of
of uh antivirals and therapeutics
per head of any european
population costa thank you madam deputy
speaker with a world-leading successful
vaccination program
with the fastest growth rate in the g7
and in my south leicestershire
constituency some of the highest
employment that we've seen in
generations
does this not demonstrate that during
this covert pandemic when it comes to
the big decisions
this prime minister and the government
he leads has got them right
[Applause]
yes mr speaker i have to say look i'm i
i'm casting modesty if not of course
yes we have uh got it right mr speaker
though there have been some very
difficult decisions and would have been
nice today finally uh to have had the
support of the opposition
madame speaker thank you i'm sure the
whole house will join me in paying
tribute to my constituent jamal edwards
a musical pioneer taken from us way too
young yesterday
the prime minister justifies this crowd
pleaser for his own mps
with um warning us about
damage to the economy but can i ask him
when the ons say that 1.3 million of our
fellow citizens are suffering from the
debilitating
condition of long covid which actually
has rendered 396 000 people economically
inactive it causes dysfunctionality
it ages people by 10 years
what is it that this premise is doing to
advance research and treatment into this
condition and how does today's exercise
help those people
[Music]
she's absolutely right to um
madame deputy speaker to mention uh the
the problem of long covid we've invested
224 million into expanding nhs treatment
uh of long covered and uh we're putting
another 50 million into into research
into that syndrome
henry smith thank you very much madam
deputy speaker i very much welcome the
prime minister's statement today a
return to liberty uh so that we can
further grow our economy so that we can
tackle those other health conditions but
can you say a little bit more
about what targeted support will be
provided for those who are
immunosuppressed and immunocompromised
such as those with blood cancer
and then one of them
i i thank you very much so uh
we've we've secured supplies of uh
monoclonal antibodies uh
as i've told the house
in uh in record numbers uh but what
we'll also do is make sure that those
who are in you know suppressed have
access to uh to testing uh to see
whether they they need the therapeutics
gavin newlands
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
that the deep irony about this prime
minister elections and personal
responsibility wouldn't be lost when the
public watching at home in terms of
kevin bridges personal responsibility
won't pay the bills
but madam deputy speaker he called for a
full nations approach time and time
again demoning any deviation and
approached in cardiff belfast or
edinburgh
now he is recklessly dangerously
dropping all restrictions in england and
in community testing without
consultation or consideration of
devolved needs and flying in the face of
the scientific advice he has been given
this just proves his full nation's
approach has implemented follow
westminster's direction no matter how
rash doesn't it
first of all mr speaker about madam
deputy speaker uh we're not dropping the
testing until the beginning of april as
he knows and it's only thanks just just
it's only thanks to the massive
financial firepower of the the uk that
we've been able to run the biggest
testing we've been able to run the
biggest testing operation in europe plus
uh the biggest uh backs of the fastest
vaccination rollout
like a fabric
deputy speaker can i ask my right
honourable friend to cast his mind back
to january last year when chris whittie
said there will come a time
when covid will be the same as flu where
actually there are seven thousand to
twenty thousand deaths each year at that
time there was no comment against him
from either the labour party or the smp
now that we have excess deaths at minus
nine percent of what is normal at this
time is he as baffled as i am about the
attitude that the labour front bench now
has
[Applause]
yes actually mr speaker i am i thank you
very much i'm genuinely surprised by
the the approach that they've taken
today i do think it is wrong but i think
he making an important point about the
comparison with flu because it is it is
very important that people with any
respiratory disease think about those
who are clinically vulnerable and and
behave resp in in a responsible and
considerate way
thank you madam deputy speak speaker a
plan for living with covet which does
not provide for older and extremely
vulnerable people which does not include
school children or sick pay for the
working people or testing isn't it the
case that this is a plan
in the same sense
only in the same sense
that his birthday was not a party
no
deputy speaker this is a uh this is a
plan that addresses every single one of
those priorities uh every single one of
those priorities uh sick pay uh schools
uh the vulnerable this plan deals with
all of them and i think it's the right
way forward and i think actually she
should support it
david evans thank you very much
i strongly welcome and endorse my
writing reference statement today
restoring our freedoms
would he agree that the restrictions
although necessary have taken a very
heavy toll on businesses and our society
and we have to live
with the virus for the future however on
this side we passionately believe in
trusting the people to take response
personal responsibility yeah
a beautifully put man mr speaker
patrick grady
a vaccine being donated as part of the
global response counted towards or in
addition to the government's 0.5 oda
target and when will it stop blocking
agreement on a trip's waiver so that
developing countries can take vaccine
response into their own hands
he's raising he's raising a very
important but very difficult issue and i
i suppose an answer to uh the honourable
lady opposite i i mentioned the
importance of the of the private sector
we do need to ensure that uh uh the
pharmaceutical companies uh have the uh
the wherewithal to make these colossal
investments uh that offer hope uh for
humanity
chris clarkson thank you um i want to
start by congratulating my right
honourable friend for his forbearance
because i crossed that dispatch box
first he was faced by the vacillations
of general indecision and then by the
rank opportunism of captain hindsight
so does my right honourable friend agree
with me did he listen to lieutenant
locke down there instead of having the
the first major economy to unlock and a
world leading vaccine program we'd now
be facing a major catastrophe
[Applause]
yes mr speaker and the the most
important thing about everything is that
we would not if we if we'd taken that
those steps if we'd remained in lockdown
we would not have the financial
wherewithal the firepower the money uh
to to pay for all the things that the
the people now need uh support with not
not least mr speaker amanda is clearing
the kobe background grant davis
thank you the prime minister says that
this is a scientific decision so can you
remind the house what the current r rate
is the reinfection rate what it's
projected to be uh by the start of may
and at what level of our rate is he
willing to reintroduce testing and
self-isolation or isn't it a scientific
decision
the the as i've said earlier on uh mad
debt speaker the uh rate of infections
are is falling and so hospitalizations
teresa villas
aspects of the pandemic has been that
many people have been unable to visit
their sick or even dying relatives in
hospital
and visiting has still been very
difficult even with the improvement in
the covert situation well will the prime
minister make sure this day
is when
nhs visiting requirements in our
hospital go back to normal because that
is the humane and compassionate thing to
do yeah yeah yeah
all right
man speak i thank my friend very much
she's i know she speaks for for millions
of people around around the country i
can tell her that many many restrictions
have uh have already been lifted and
they and will continue to be lifted
stephen timms
thank you very much three years ago the
government consulted on much needed
reforms to statutory sick pay rightly
recognizing that the current system is
inflexible and doesn't reflect modern
working life those reforms were
postponed when the pandemic hit and
instead day one access to statutory sick
pay was introduced i think he's just
announced that day one access to statute
pay you can be withdrawn in a month's
time will he then now bring forward the
much needed and long delayed reforms to
statutory thick pay
as
knows that uh statutory sick pay is only
a part of what many employees uh already
receive us as part of their sick bank
duncan baker
to remind people the prime minister was
right last july when we came out of
lockdown and we're going to leave the
prime minister's statement on covid
restrictions in the commons there and uh
we are back in ukraine with some
breaking news uh this evening and that
is that uh vladimir putin the president
of russia is due to make a statement to
the nation according to state media in
moscow and he will do that uh pretty
soon sometime we think within the next
half an hour it all follows a
meeting of his uh security council an
unscheduled meeting of his security
council
earlier today uh joining me now is our
security and defense editor
deborah haynes and as i was saying uh
deborah it follows this
rather odd
and very very public uh security council
meeting earlier today and now this
address for the nation
yes it was quite an extraordinary
um session wasn't it that we saw on
television of president putin and his
top security chiefs and foreign minister
uh it sort of seemed almost theatrical
as they discussed through their version
of events in terms of what's happening
here in ukraine and president putin
during that meeting it was all kind of
about whether or not or what to do about
the situation in the donbass region and
those two breakaway regions uh regions
of um luhansk and donetsk that has been
the heart of this froze what had been a
frozen conflict in ukraine since the
annexation by russia of crimea back in
2014 and the backing of
of separatists there and the president
saying that he would make a decision
today on whether to recognize the
independence of those two regions were
he to do that analysts have said that
could provide
a pretext potentially for russia to send
military troops overtly into those
regions uh under the guise of offering
some kind of protection over the last
few days we've we've heard claims that
citizens there
under threat from the ukrainian armed
forces we've seen
pictures of them being transported
over the border into russia ukraine's
government has categorically denied any
such posing any such threat and there's
not been any independently verifiable
evidence to suggest that the claims of
this threat are true in fact far more
likely is that this is the pretext
potentially that western officials have
said they expect president putin to
concoct
in order to justify military action
potentially
in ukraine we aren't there yet but this
is a worrying step were that to happen
and the fact that you now have president
putin addressing his nation
we don't know exactly what he's going to
say but if it's about this issue which
you can imagine it most like